On to if else statements.
You saw several if else statements in
Swift when we talked about operators.
If else statements take the form, if,
a condition to evaluate, a statement
to execute if the condition is met.
Else, a statement to execute
if the condition is not met.
Notice again that it's not necessary to
place the condition within parentheses
as you might do in C or Java.
It is necessary to place
the statements between curly braces.
Now let's revisit some of
the statements from lesson one.
Here we've got a bole called Hungry.
If hungry is true, let's eat.
Otherwise, let's wait.
We can use logical operators to
build more complicated conditions.
Here we're adding a second bole,
Vegetarian.
If hungry is true and
vegetarian is false let's eat steak.
If hungry is true and vegetarian
is true let's eat pumpkin curry.
Otherwise forget about it.
We can go for coffee or margaritas.
Similarly, in example three.
If hungry is true or if there is pie is
true, let's eat, otherwise, nevermind.
And that's it for now.
If else statements and
Swift are pretty intuitive.